next up on the program is my friend brad
stone
he is a senior executive editor for
global technology my god that's a long
title bro at bloomberg uh bloomberg news
i guess would be the correct way to say
it uh you also know him as the author of
the everything store jeff bezos in the
age of amazon 2013 the upstarts uber
airbnb and the battle for the new
silicon valley 2017 and
he's back at the amazon uh trough again
reporting on it's a good way to put it
yeah i mean it's just it's the gift that
keeps on giving amazon unbound jeff
bezos in
and the innovation of a global empire
2021 but welcome back to the program
brad how you holding up thanks jason i'm
well you know the the pandemic was uh
actually weirdly or perversely a good
time to write a book
uh because i i would have been i would
have been quarantining anyway so you
know it kind of worked out it you know i
just started writing my my second book
and i was in italy and i stayed a week
longer went to the beach and you know
the family went home and i had the most
productive week of my life i'm curious
for you as a writer
what is your process
and and how do you get the words to flow
how many words a day do you hit
typically take us through that just
let's go inside baseball
sure sure um you know i kind of like to
say that the only thing worse than
writing a book and being on deadline and
being in the midst of it is not being in
the midst of it right it's like i i need
i need the focus um and the deadlines uh
and the i maybe like the sort of mental
activity of having a project like that
and what i do and when the story is
great as it is with with amazon you know
in the last 10 years
um it's kind of it's like a brain virus
i'm going to sleep thinking about i'm
waking up and you know my productive
times in the morning um
you know i kind of feel like
a good goal for me is like a thousand
words a day you know it's just it's and
and that's my goal i've usually got it
outlined i i i wake up early um
and um you know and and i
and that gives me like the whole day to
kind of marinate on it what i how what i
want to write the next day how i'm going
to approach the material um and if you
can do that and stay disciplined
you know then 100 you know 100 or 120
000 uh 120 000 word book is within reach
and you know i kept my you know i had my
day job at bloomberg and so and i've got
kids and i was doing a bunch of other
things but that was the goal a thousand
words a day
um and when you write it do you can you
multitask on other things during the day
or i wonder if you're like me where if
there's other things going on i seem to
have a hard time getting the words to
flow you'd have that distraction so if i
go to another location and i'm out of my
house i'm out of my office i'm turning
my email off and i'm just focusing for
that like four to six hour block of just
trying to get the words to flow and i
typically when i do that i can get that
thousand to two thousand word a day
thing going and like you're saying i i
get that hint
that when you're in that zone it's
almost like you can't write fast enough
right the words can't come up fast
enough and you're you're like oh that's
a chapter that's a chapter that's a
section oh
and you're just like how do i get it out
fast enough and then there's other times
when it's extremely frustrating i would
suspect
yeah yeah i i um i can i can multitask
but on on different kinds of things so
this i'll i i probably couldn't
multitask on another writing project
that would interfere
but you know me meetings
um editing other people's stories some
of my other responsibilities of
bloomberg um that i find easy to do um
it's just like when i when i'm working
on a book project that's my that's
taking up my the kind of writing part
of my brain and anything that would be
too similar to that i i wouldn't want to
embark on a on a magazine story when i'm
when i'm working on a book project i
think that would interfere
when you think about non-fiction writing
and telling the stories of businesses
and entrepreneurs
what do you think the key is in terms of
writing the pros and and story
architecture do you have any insights in
that now that you've done it a couple
times yeah a company like amazon poses
a massive challenge i mean people want
to understand readers want to read these
stories chronologically that is the way
the brain works that is the best way to
tell stories there's a great you know
there are many millennia of uh you know
demonstration into that and the problem
the challenge with the amazon is that
everything's happening at once and you
know you not only have different
business initiatives but the you know
the central story which is the
transformation of jeff bezos almost
before our eyes from the the geek who
extol the the technical specs of the
fire phone to the guy gallivanting
around hollywood um retiring from amazon
and building a super yacht um you know
this so it really was an organizational
challenge how do i tell the story
horizontally across the last 10 years
but also vertically
the alexa story the amazon ghost story
the indian china story hollywood and
then hq2 antitrust and bezos his own
personal drama and you know you see how
i did it in the book it's um i started
2010 with bezos coming up with the idea
of alexa i end in 2020 and some of the
increased anti-trust scrutiny and amazon
navigating the pandemic and so the
horizontal story is kind of teased
throughout but there are also chapters
devoted to alexa and go and india and
hollywood so you just have to do a
little bit of both
steven levy who you know once told yeah
once told me this thing that for a long
time i had up on my wall um it was this
advice he said find the straight line
and that's the thread that is takes you
from the beginning to the end of the
story so however many digressions
diversions or chapters subheadings you
go into
always always keep the straight line in
mind you know the beginning to the end
what what do you think the straight line
of and i want to get into let's just get
into jeff as a person
um
what is the straight line of jeff bezos
well i mean it's it's the
uh
yeah i don't know if it's how straight
it is there's many zones and zags but
you know roughly speaking it's a guy who
you know had a successful career on wall
street in the early 90s who quit his job
to bet big and bet early on the internet
um and you know and over the course of
25 years many ups and downs being
written off as almost the
personification of dot-com hubris at one
point
became the richest guy in the world
built a recognizable corporate franchise
that's changed the world um and in the
process changed himself you know and
became a much different person
and a very polarizing and controversial
figure so you know yeah roughly speaking
it's an incredible journey he looks
different he sounds different he you
know some things have remained the same
um but uh he sometimes i l i look or i
listen i went to his rocket launch in
van horn texas and sometimes i don't
recognize him he's he's changed quite a
bit
before we get into the ad let me just
tell you straight up linkedin.com twist
your first job posting free i'm not
kidding linkedin.com twist your first
job listing free nothing to lose okay
now on to the end too many small
business owners are busier than ever
they spend time searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates for a
job opening and it would be much better
for them to spend their time growing
their business that's why linkedin jobs
has made it easier to get the candidates
worth interviewing faster and that's why
they're giving you the first job listing
for free at linkedin.comtwist
they know it's gonna work here's how it
works you create a free post in minutes
on linkedin jobs and you reach the
world's largest professional network
with over 750 million people i remember
reading this ad when it was like 150
million my god they're growing it's like
one of the biggest growth stories inside
of microsoft in fact so they focus on
candidates with the skills and
experience that you need and you can use
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified people we
love linkedin jobs at launch and in 2021
we've hired a third producer a
curriculum designer for founder
university and two more researchers and
we're still hiring for three more
positions using you guessed it linkedin
jobs so linkedin jobs will help you find
the candidates that are worth
interviewing faster every week nearly 40
million job seekers visit linkedin so
post your job for free at linkedin.com
twist terms and conditions apply because
they're giving you something for free
okay let's get back to the program